the House Committee on the judiciary is
introducing two articles of impeachment
charging the President of the United
States Donald J Trump with committing
high crimes and misdemeanors the first
article is for abuse of power this gives
rise to the second article of
impeachment for obstruction of Congress
so that's it two accusations that are so
vague they can mean anything and nothing
which is the point after all when there
is no crime you got to leave it to the
imagination and boy is this open to
interpretation it's like a Rorschach
test for the blind which suits the media
perfectly remember how this process was
reverse engineered it wasn't here's a
crime let's impeach it was let's impeach
and hope we find the crime it's the
holiday reboot of let's pass the bill to
see what's in it
Pelosi's last big hit and what a flop
worse than Angry Birds - and we knew it
yet we still had to carry the farce
despite it featuring clowns who joked
about Baron and played dishonestly
edited clips of Trump but while the
press tortured viewers by pretending it
mattered one question remained why
didn't the Republicans just bolt after
all we all knew it was just a stupid
skit designed to make Dems feel good
since they're immune to feeling stupid
the rest of us are left with what cops
call the mess meaning when thieves break
into a house and find zilch the only
thing left to do is trash the place
hence the amorphous abuse of power which
anyone can now use on the Dems and they
should I mean when you move forward with
a three-year witch trial knowing the
only support will be partisan and
therefore doomed to fail while boasting
that you'll keep doing it forever
isn't that an abuse of power it's
certainly an abuse of America's patience
institutions trust and cohesion which
makes it another media assisted oakes
collusion covington Cavanaugh now this
if you want to find the lie just look
where the media points its cameras I
have the theory Dana I would like to
share with you I do too okay so I
believe this impeachment process
satisfies the media while helping Trump
in key battleground states
yes so what does that sound like it
reminds me of CNN and MSNBC primarily
Morning Joe doing non stop mocking
coverage of Trump which their media and
their ratings enjoyed but got him
elected
so are they too stupid is Morning Joe
and CNN just too stupid to see that the
reelecting Trump just like the
impeachment inquiry so the absolutely
the polling shows that two things
nationally Republicans and Democrats
nothing has changed
okay so the numbers are the exact same
as they were not even just three months
ago when impeachment was announced but
three years ago when the president was
elected and the number of people who
disapprove of the presidency is that the
like fifty three percent right and the
that was the remember what did Hillary
Clinton get in the popular vote about
that number
nothing has been persuasive on either
side both sides are completely locked in
except in one place and that is in the
key battleground states Michigan
Wisconsin Pennsylvania and those three
states in the last three months
impeachment has absolutely heard the
Democrats and it has helped President
Trump if President were if President
Trump were to lose next November it will
not be because of impeachment right that
will absolutely not be the case and also
it was just announced that the House
Judiciary Committee is going to move so
quickly that tomorrow night at 7:00 p.m.
is when they're going to start the
mark-up that means in the committee
they're basically saying here's the
final details of what we're gonna go
forward so who says Congress can't move
quickly yes exactly I think the reason
they want to move quickly is they wanted
to rip the band-aid off get this over
with because they know that politically
while it was important for their base
they need to move on so that they can
try to try to I guess argue on the
merits going into November don't tell
Andrew Johnson I think he was impeached
in three days but that was the fourth
time but I would say this about the
numbers that Dana was citing accurately
that what I said thank you
well of course but I do think that if
you look at the numbers and almost half
the country favoring impeachment and
removal that's unprecedented I mean I go
to Bill Clinton and it was only like 29
days of the media at the max no I think
look I think the media is on both sides
of this I think there's conservative
media there's liberal or I don't know
look whatever there's all peyer's
there's all kinds of media where people
want to be simply have their
pre-existing opinions affirmed but I
will say that to my mind when you look
at an allegation like bribery Gregg and
you say oh good point
I didn't see I don't see the bribery
charge right and I see this big bucket I
would say 1 Oh what's gee I guess it
wasn't a fishing expedition it was done
in good faith and this is what they
think or two that when you look at abuse
of power
bribery would be included in such a
charge look so-called quid pro quo
allegation right no yeah there's mera
but you're right though the bribery just
kind of went away do we have a bribery
montage that we could throw to at this
point that makes us look incredibly
sophisticated evidence shows an
impeachable offense bribery abuse of
power and obstructions yes there was a
lot of evidence of bribery there's a
substantial amount of evidence on the
abuse of power on the question of
bribery you can call this extortion
called bribery it's all the same thing
did the president's demands on Ukraine
constitute bribery or treason bribery or
acts of omission and in this case it is
it's clearly one of those trees and
bribery high crime bribery high crimes
and misdemeanors what happened to the
bribery well I think it's in that bucket
I was talking about use the power but I
think the bucket is so amorphous that
the Dems are now swimming in that bucket
no I think that they were actually as I
said acting in good faith now I think
you're saying not a fishing like see
they kick the bucket say that I would
when I I think I can't believe that
we're talking about left-wing media
right-wing media how this report gets
interpreted well you know all of this
even what we're talking about here what
about the fact that it's Trump's people
bringing these charges from Finland to
Sandlin to Taylor to you I mean these
are state 1
let me get Jesse in here Jesse the first
impeachment probably in history based on
emotional trauma yeah I mean the two
articles really are we hate you and we
can't beat you
not not anything here what do you have
first she had no collusion then there
was no extortion no bribery
they're just settling on things one they
say obstruction of justice because Trump
said I'll see you in court every
president tells Congress I'll see you in
court
you can't impeach someone for saying let
a judge decide and then the other one
abuse of power by that standard every
single president could have been
impeached by that very low standard they
tried to rush this thing the American
people saw there was flimsy and then
they lost interest in it and now
everyone's just talking about football
and the irishman this is what's going to
happen 10 of these Democrats in Trump
districts now in the house they want to
censure they don't even want to vote on
impeachment they're nervous and like you
said you're right
Trump was losing to these three
Democratic contenders in these
battleground states a month ago now he's
meeting them all by a lot and he's had a
great year in 2019 he killed back daddy
blockbuster job numbers now they're
passing new NAFTA I mean any exposed a
deep state which we haven't even gotten
into so it's been a good year let me
talk to you know Emily if you're like me
before I watch a movie I always go to
Wikipedia to look at the plot summary
cuz I don't like surprises I never look
at Wikipedia all ready knew the plot and
we're watching this thing unfold we
already know where it's gonna go which
is in the Senate go poof this is true
which is why it's such a surprise that
bribery isn't in there and I hear what
you're saying which is that you are
saying it's included in this but I think
that's what is difficult for the average
citizen to wrap their brain around is
the fact that this writing is very
amorphous it is ambiguous what does this
mean where for a president Trump he's
demonstrated he will remain a threat to
national security I'm used to trust a
strategy that hits elements of a crime
that presents to a jury here are the
elements of this crime here's the code
that is the law and the year is
therefore why this defendant committed a
crime what we have here is literally a
thesis yeah and I think what's difficult
to stomach about it is that we've been
hearing messaging from the left this
entire time including quotes like
President Trump is a criminal and with
that word specifically bribery with it
magically disappeared and with these
counts not be mutually exclusive they're
not joint or sorry they're not join
there's several meaning why don't we
twice it they're more if they were that
intent on catching someone who was
abusing power then why wouldn't they try
from A to Z and hoping one would stick
because just one is enough to remove him
from power if it's persuasive the answer
is it's not it's you know what goes back
to that what we said before these are
what if ours what the if errs they don't
know what could happen so they what if
this happens this could happen in the
future they're trying to prosecute them
for future crimes it's just like
Minority Report that great movie with
Tom Cruise if you're looking about hmm
how does this play out I think he gets
impeached mm-hmm well we shall see Juan